I didn't want to say a few words about
this remarkably cheap and
extraordinarily attractive what that
I've written
um I read a little of it every night
before I go to sleep marveling at the
lucidity of its language the atlas of
its imagery the incisiveness of its
insights you too can share this ecstatic
if you see me later
you've got a three handshake from the
author two copies you get a kiss well
you might prefer to stick with Wally in
that case you know somebody who wrote to
me of enthusiastic letter about the book
from the Australian outback and so
enthusiastic was he that he said him why
didn't you call it
why marks is right and I wrote back and
said I'm he's dead maybe it takes a long
time for news you know to travel to the
outback in a tree the bush I get quite a
lot of hate mail as most left wingers
and the public eye I suppose do but
nature in her wisdoms provided that him
all far right-wing cranks have the same
erratic huge handwriting this is a kind
of evolutionary device further nature in
her wisdom has seen fit to you so that
you know you steel yourself for the
desire for you to get some loathsome
disease you know everybody's been
looking at the envelope marks has of
course been an extraordinary caricature
I mean what one of the most travesty of
writers I think more so even I think
them Freud Freud's pretty caricatured
because the gauze mark is a political
writer that probably cancer solve it
people who think for example that Freud
believes that everything comes down to
sex
now that's actually right being
Christians so it's not Freudian I see
or talk learnedly about the Freudian
subconscious there's no concept of the
subconscious in fact in Freud so I want
in this brief time to list to talk about
10 things 10 aspects of Marx that most
people don't know about you will in a
few minutes know about them nobody else
will you will have a certain moral and
intellectual superiority to practice
wherever you wish amaze your friends
just points that run against the grain
as it were of the most that the banal
received wisdom about Marx first of all
the fact that he was of course a great
champion of capitalism yeah how many
people in the BBC for example know that
that for Marx the middle class is the
European middle classes have created
capitalism where the most by far for him
the most revolutionary agent in history
and he had undying praise for them in
fact Hannah Arendt
said that the opening pages of the
communist manifesto or an embarrassing
paean of praise to capitalism yes and
Marx thought that in its brief existence
capitalism had revolutionized the face
of the earth they'd had accumulated
fabulous riches but spiritual as well as
material riches civil rights democracy
as we know today feminism liberalism if
it accumulated given us all of these
things along with Mel Gibson and Lady
gaga and so on what has to be rather
shaded about this no it had swept away
in an astonishingly brief period of time
almost every vestige of the osteon
regimes apart from a few perhaps you
know not very easily observed remnant
such as Prince Charles or some other
why with those ears he wouldn't be
easily observed it's a mystery
and it was this four marks all of this
enormous accumulation of progress
enlightenment of liberalism of
progressivism it was this that had to
form the basis for socialism Marx was
absolutely clear that he said without
that the enormous legacy of treasures
that the revolutionary middle class had
deleted bequeathed to the future indeed
for the most of course self-interested
and discreditable and narrowly selfish
reasons but nonetheless without that
basis for Marx any socialism would be
bankrupt from the outset in other words
what he was really doing in a sense was
prefiguring what came to be known as
Stalinism the doomed attempt to
construct socialism in the least
propitious conditions in the most
desperately backward conditions one of
the tragedies of the 20th century I
think in that respect was that socialism
was most necessary where it was least
possible but in a sense the whole of
Marx's work argues against that he
admires and praises the riches of
capitalism but of course being a
dialectical thinker he also sees the
enormous poverty and deprivation and
sheer human wretchedness that it's
created so much so indeed that one might
ask the question even if a just society
were to stagger out from this sordid
history of class oppression and conflict
could any such society retrospectively
justify a suffering which had gone into
its making it's not a question that Marx
himself particularly point poses but I
think it's a question that we can how is
it that in the midst of the greatest
most fabulous affluence history has ever
known men and women in Greece as I speak
rummaging in garbage cans for food for
themselves and their children what are
the contradiction was Marxist asking
which make poverty and wealth sides of
the same coin as close as the two sides
of a piece of paper
why does freedom for a few turn into
oppression for many why does equality
twist
by some constant mechanism into
inequality and so what was really
wanting to ask the question of what
underlying mechanisms created this
situation but what he looked forward to
was not labor a society of labor which
people associated marks but leisure
Marx's whole aim was to create a society
the seer society in which as far as
feasible
and he was pretty realistic about this
men and women could be released from
undignified forms of toil and drudgery
his ideal society not that he talks
about in those terms would thus be
pretty much like Oscar Wilde's in his
great pamphlet the soul of man under
socialism where mark where wild in the
visitors the future really as just
lounging around all day in loose crimson
garments sipping absinthe and reciting
homer to each other and that's just the
working day I wasn't him to describe the
leisure time yeah ma you know Wilde was
an east heat and a socialist in a very
logical kind of way because he thought
that the whole point ultimately of human
existence was to realize one's powers
and capacities purely for their own sake
or to use a more technical theological
term purely for the Hellenic yes like
all the best things of course are done
in that sense purely for their own self
delighted mark stood in that tradition
he wasn't East beat in manner of wild
but wild would certainly but have
recognized himself and his own work in
that you can't actually of course
pre-program or pre-draft human freedom
which is one reason why Marx as a
secular Jew observes the Judaic
prohibition on graven images of the
future graven images of the kingdom how
could you possibly using the poor
materials of the present predict or give
an image of the future the future must
in that sense go beyond the present
there's no image of it available and
Marxism
tourist Asylum Tom the shape a socialist
society would take and the only image of
the future is the failure of the present
as far as he's concerned and socialism
for him would be to go back to the point
about wild and asceticism it's a matter
of production and everybody knows that
Marx worked as associate of the concept
of production but his notion of
production is extraordinary generous and
deep you know for Marx eating of peach
is production you know as though is the
realization of sensuous human capacities
listening to Mozart is production it's
not just talking about middle worthless
or coalmines
his idea is is idealist society in which
men and women could realize their powers
and capacities the phrase uses
continually purely for their own self
delight and that's the reason why as far
as market is concerned the image of
production here averts to again and
again is art art is Martha's image of
ideal production typical human
production John simply for the love and
the hell of it he was of course himself
a staggeringly erudite Central European
intellectual know who seemed to have
read everything there was and he
bitterly regretted having to spend so
much time writing Capitao nobody he once
said had written so much about money and
had so little yes
he bitterly regretted that he wanted to
write his big book on Bowser which he'd
planned right but he thought that it
would be irresponsible of him not to
write on economics and the reason he
wrote on economics was not because he
believed that was the be-all and end-all
on the contrary as I say his ideal was
leisure are not labor as far as possible
he worked on economics because he wanted
to diminish its tyrannical grip over
human lives he wanted to as it were
background the economic against the
conventional rather banal wisdom of him
if men and women were to realize their
powers and capacities as delightful ends
in themselves how does that differ from
a certain classical liberal model in
which everybody as it were does their
own thing you know has their own space
in which to fulfill themselves but
pretty much as atoms in isolation from
each other
well marx had a kind of answer to that
that really he'd be pinched from Hegel
I'd be pinched a lot of stuff from Hegel
which was that in any complex society
men and women could only realize their
capacities in and through the self
realization of other people yes indeed
there's a phrase of the Communist
Manifesto that in socialism or
communists and the self realization of
each will become the condition for the
self realization of all which captures
just a pity kind of way that that ideal
if you think of that in interpersonal
terms if you think of a situation in
which the self realization of one person
as an end in itself is done in and
through the self realization of
something else you're talking about love
and what Marx is really talking about is
a kind of political love what will
believe necessary institutions for that
actually to happen think for example of
a cooperative a self-governing
cooperative which seems to have been
part of Marx's vision of a good society
it's just in the nature of those
cooperatives that people by doing what
they
by taking part actually do augment and
create the conditions for the greater
self realization of the other people
involved
there's no need here for some kind of
heroic altruism or self-conscious
martyrdom or striving you know the
greatest food of the greatest number
that is built into the institution as it
is and that seems to have been part of
Marx's aim he didn't as it happens he
wasn't a great champion of equality
again as people think you know that his
ideal Society is when we all all wear
the same you know boiler suits with our
National Insurance numbers stamped on
the back you know and actually it's
capitalism addresses everybody the same
you know in track suit and trainers yeah
that's the true uniformity he act Marx
actually thought equality was really a
bourgeois notion yeah a certain kind of
abstract leveling of individuals
he wasn't opposed to it just on those
grounds Marx thought many bourgeois
notions were highly progressive but he
thought that it was falsifying it was
commodities which exchanged abstractly
for mark should not human beings and the
reason he objected that was because he
was a good old romantic humanist who was
passionately devoted to the reality of
the specific individual another point
about Marx which fails to get through in
the general consciousness he had an
abiding suspicion of the abstract which
meant he also had an abiding suspicion
of theory yes
he thought of course for the abstract
was necessary in an analysis of society
but he talks rather strikingly about
rising from the abstract to the concrete
the abstract is something you've kind of
begin with something very general yes
but you have to progressively refine
that into that set of rich in particular
determinations which constitute an
individual thing and that includes an
individual life well one of the rather
powerful combinations in Marx's thought
I think it's hard to beat you
raise is the fact that he was at once an
old-fashioned romantic humanist as his
passion for the particular suggests but
he was also an Enlightenment rationalist
so that he didn't leave built of the
universal he didn't relinquish his grasp
on the need for global community which
he thought capitalism had prepared the
way for but he wanted that to be
mediated in and through a respect for
the individual in all of his or her
diversity and plurality all of these
terms
long before post-modernism a part of
Marx's own language he was of course as
hostile to the state as the tea party is
if four rather more credible reason yes
state socialism for Marx would have been
a contradiction in terms
socialism was democratic or it was
nothing
democratic socialism for Marx is a
tautology just as as business ethics is
an oxymoron
Mark's disagreed with parliamentary
democracy which again with a very
qualified judgment I mean marks of
course was a Doughty supporter and
champion of many reform bills
he didn't naively opposed reform to
revolution but Marx disagreed with
parliamentary democracy because he
thought it wasn't democratic enough it
didn't extend in a popular grassroots
decentralized way into society as a
whole and it certainly didn't extend
into the into the economy he was not
again whatever people may imagine it was
not a utopian thinker I've already
mentioned the fact that he has a kind of
embargo on predicting the future he
began his career in contention with
utopian thinkers various kinds he
learned from people like fumio-san
Seymour he didn't particularly
appreciate for his dream that under
utopian conditions the ocean would turn
into lemonade which was a point for the
claim you probably would have preferred
you know a rather fine Riesling or
something with anger but he wasn't the
utopian and he spent much time
criticizing that whole vein of political
thought in the sense that he there's
nothing that I know in Marxist work to
suggest that he believed in a perfect
society absolutely not the word on the
contrary the very notion of materialism
would suggest that he believed that
reality was pretty messy and imperfect
and unfinished
there's nothing to suggest in Marx that
the future you know even under socialism
won't have its fair quota of cheats and
bullies and freeloaders and the
occasional psychopath and Simon Cowell
and and so on you know absolutely
nothing this work suggests that simply
that we have reached a historical stage
and capitalism for him is to be thanked
ironically for bringing us to it where
it is feasible that men and women's
lives could be a lot less wretched than
they are but that's very different from
some
dream of perfection what about
revolution which is a sticking point
with so many people first of all as I
said Marx made no naive contrast between
revolution and reform he was very stout
and committed reformist and of course as
far as violence goes we know that many
processes are reformed have been more
bloody than some revolutions there are
delicate revolutions as well as violent
ones but most processes of reform of a
protracted period of time have involved
quite a lot of violence and aggression
and bloodshed people say they don't like
revolutions but usually they're thinking
of particular revolutions a lot of
others most people approve say of the
American Revolution approve of the
revolution against apartheid approve of
the revolutions that brought down the
neo Stalin estates of Eastern Europe
approve of the Arab Spring its
particular revolutions that people tend
to object to in doing so of course they
forget very often that they themselves
are the products of a long drawn-out
revolutionary process which came to a
particular focus of violence in the mid
17th century but which was one of those
most successful revolutions which as it
were wipes itself from the minds of
humanity all the best revolutions are
those which survive long enough to be
able to be thrust into the political
unconscious as though they never
happened which is one reason why states
which are still fairly recent Northern
Ireland Israel a few others have a
problem with legitimacy for Edmund Burke
the great Irish political theorist
longevity was legitimacy the longer you
survived the more you could thrust the
primordial trespass into the unconscious
the better you were we know that most
states were founded by
revolution or occupation or invasion or
usurpation or in some cases even
extermination but the trick is to bring
it about over a long period of time that
that never actually happened um all
right let me just add a couple of points
and then we can talk about it marked is
famous for his commitment to the
proletariat
and and people say well whatever
happened to that surely were in a
different situation
well Marx was well aware that the mid
majority of working people in his own
society in Victorian England weren't
blue-collar male factory workers at all
manufacturing workers they were domestic
workers and domestic workers of course
were overwhelmingly women they were the
skivvies and the maidservants and the
cooks over the Victorian middle classes
Marx was well aware of that he thought
that the proletariat had a specifically
important role to play in a
revolutionary process but he never made
the mistake of imagining but it was
anything like the majority of working
people in the society Pro the word
proletariat of course comes from the
book the word the word crowley's which
is same kind of word as progeny really
means offspring it means children it
means those people in ancient societies
who were too poor to serve the state
with anything but the fruit of their
wombs women who produced labour power in
the form of individual human beings
today in a global society the
proletariat remains largely a woman
remains female sweated labour throughout
the world one of the most striking
aspects of Marx I'll end with this is
that he is and angles his thoughts about
the environment are quite astonishingly
ahead of their time I mean I think
there's absolutely no doubt that yeah
and as in the old cliche if Marx and
Engels were alive today they will be in
the van
on ecological politics it's true that
there is a so-called Promethean straight
in Marxist thought which is what his
enemies and projects remember and all
they tend to remember on this topic as
to say the Enlightenment domination of
nature but Marx and Engels are much more
commonly found to be talking in terms
that could almost be contemporary of the
necessity for the Lions of dialogue or
symbiosis a friendship and exchange of
energies and so on with the natural
world and of course a belief recognition
of how capitalism how predatory
capitalism is in relation to that angles
perhaps blotted his copybook a little
bit on the topic he was a he rode with
the Cheshire hunt but as I say you know
materialism means that nothing is
perfect and nobody and I think I'll end
there having convinced you so completely
that there's not even I think any need
for dialogue on this matter so we can
just repair to the nearest pub you know
and did Marx have his faults lots a lot
of them and some of them recorded within
this remarkable book of mine and his
prediction was when he did make them
were lousy absolutely appalling yet he
almost always got it wrong it
particularly was journalism but all I'm
arguing here is that he was right enough
of the time to make a respect for him
reasonable and he was certainly
important enough to be rescued from the
small savage travesties of his critics
thank you very much yeah